all right hi
my name is ben engber i'm the founder of
the company called thumbtack technology
we are a consulting company with one of
our primary
practice areas being doing no sql
development and advising clients on
nosql
and the background of this talk is you
know one of the things that comes up
really often when we talk to clients one
of the first things they ask us is
what sql database what nosql database
should we use
um and then you know the follow-up is
well we need to learn a little bit about
your business
so let's do some discovery and that's
it's the correct answer but it often
doesn't go over that well
and so what we wanted to do is we want
to have a you know sort of at least a
basic
uh baseline that we can introduce into
some of the main concepts
to give them right off the bat and then
sort of introduce a deeper discussion
based on that
so about six months ago we started a
research wing
within our company to do some uh nosql
evaluations and research on the subject
and
this presentation sort of presents a way
that we can compare across these
products
so in some ways what i'm going to do is
come in and argue with everything that
will just said
about why you can't build an abstraction
layer
i love it now it's actually a good
compliment here because
you know of course these products are
different and you've got to be pretty
careful
in what you're going to do and comparing
them is pretty difficult
so all the use cases he described other
use cases people have
and this is going to walk through our
experiences in trying to do this
extraction layer
and sort of a solution around that so i
think it'll go
fairly well all right so as i said
we get interest all the time in no sql
databases
and people coming to us range from
clients that
have heard the hot buzzword nosql and
have decided to use it but haven't
decided what to do
often that's a very bad idea to very
technical companies who
actually maybe have already implemented
various types of nosql solutions but are
bumping into
performance problems or data modeling
problems and so forth
some of the problems that people have is
that a lot of the
published literature out there and so
forth comparing these
is kind of riddled with different kinds
of problems a lot of the benchmark
studies which is often the first place
people go
are sort of quick and dirty things where
people just sort of
do default installs databases run some
queries against them and
make conclusions they really can't make
um there's a lot of bad reports out
there
um and then others sort of delve into
somewhat obscure things like the cap
theorem
does do people here know what the cap
theorem is
so all right so about half a cap theorem
is actually very
simple to describe it essentially says
the c is for data consistency
the a is for data availability is your
system up
and p is partition tolerance which
essentially means
can you handle network failures the
capture basically says you can choose
two of those
so it's easy to describe and also i
would argue
mostly misses the point when people talk
about this and this is the point because
if you're implementing one of these
systems
you have a network and your network will
fail so you got to be partition tolerant
and consistency and availability
probably doesn't mean
exactly what you think it means and
trying to compare things
on these dimensions just leads to more
confusion
so what we wanted to do was sort of take
some of these theoretical discussions
and turn it into
business cases and try and answer some
some use cases and
some business use cases and technical
terms for people
so why use nosql at all i actually think
most people come up with a version of
what will talked about you
you need to handle a large number of
transactions you need to handle a lot of
data data
and you don't want to deal with
crazy problems and tremendous manual
overhead when systems go down and you
need to recover and so forth
uh last bullet that a lot of people come
with is you want rapid application
development
and having schema storage is useful in
that way but it's not
really something that's easily
quantifiable so i'm going to focus on
the first three bullets
so we had this great plan of how we have
this new research wing
we are going to do a whole bunch of
stuff the first thing we were going to
do was be
really really simple i'm just going to
take a big bunch of databases
we're just going to do a very simple key
value storage
test we'll use the yahoo cloud serving
benchmark which is
as much of a standard as you can kind of
get for this although
that itself is riddled with problems
and just take some of the existing
studies out there and apply it to
a new use case that hadn't really been
studied too much that is
we're still doing key value storage but
let's measure it against bare metal and
solve
solid-state drives and because that is
pretty much what people
who are handling really high volumes are
going to need to have to buy anyway
and then once we have that we're going
to release a series of other reports
we're going to study secondary indices
we're going to
bring in all kinds of other databases
we're going to measure data loss
and this was just going to be a nice
quick beginning just to do that
and boy were we wrong on that
this this was much much harder to do
than we thought it's hard to do not only
because these databases are different in
terms of
how do you size your data set and the
row sizes and the configuration
parameters
but fundamentally they work in very
different ways they have we've talked
about cap and we'll go into it but
fundamentally they take very different
steps
to achieve these different kinds of
things and it's very hard to compare
them on equal terms so what we quickly
found was
it was the first question we had to
cover was how do we even make a fair
comparison of these databases
so we first thing we do is we
drastically reduce the number of
databases we are going to cover we
brought it down to
as i said aerospike mongodb couch base
and cassandra
we chose those because those were the
four that clients most often came to us
aerospike's probably less known than
some of the rest
but in ag tech which is where we're we
have a strong presence it's very well
known
plus they have a database specifically
geared towards ssds
so it's an obvious choice uh use the
standard client
and um like
i think i went backwards here all right
oh sorry i need to why am i going
backwards all right
time for keyboard
all right
all right so fundamentally um
once we get these baselines in place we
will just do some basic performance
measurements on them
and then after that we're going to look
into what it means when they encounter
hardware failures all right
the first thing we did was break these
performance baselines into two different
scenarios
we called them fast and reliable
essentially meant we're going to we're
going to configure these databases
to serve as much traffic as they can
without regard to your ability to lose
data
to retain data that means principle
asynchronous replication
asynchronous writes to disks keep all
your data in ram on the nodes
it doesn't doesn't necessarily mean not
consistent i will talk about why in the
middle
in a minute another thing to mention
here is that
when we say fast it doesn't mean it's
not reliable data the data still gets
written to disk
you know it still gets replicated to
other nodes it just
doesn't do it synchronously and reliable
is simply the converse we're just going
to take the data make sure it gets to
ssd
and not consider any writes valid until
it's written to disk
and and replicate it
to describe how to do this you sort of
need to go into how these databases
function
as i mentioned these databases are
wildly different from one another
so please bear with me there's there's
going to be four pictures here of what
goes on
touch base in many ways is the easiest
to describe
it's essentially memcached with
replication and persistence
and you basically this is this is a
hypothetical cluster
of six nodes there's data on various
shards
spread across it in each one of these
we're assuming a replication factor of
three here
so each node is a master for one shard
and there are two slaves for each shard
and couchbase
is a consistent database but it achieves
this very simply
it just always reads and writes from the
master
the fast scenario very easy to describe
it reads and writes to a master and
returns immediately doesn't wait for the
data to replicate
you have the option of asking couchbase
to wait until that data is replicated
now you have consistency
mongodb works very much the same way but
it uses a more traditional mysql master
slave replication model
but essentially you either wait for the
right to succeed
and get propagated or you don't
cassandra is where it gets a little more
interesting there's no way you're going
to be able to interpret this so bear
with me
but i want to talk about it because this
really starts to illustrate
why this notion of available and
consistent starts getting
really confused all right cassandra
in the fast case you have a single
client
that's going to read to a node or write
from a node
but which node you're reading to is
completely independent
so if you write to a node eventually
it's going to make it to some of the
other nodes in the cluster
and if you read from a node that node is
eventually going to get the data you
want
but as you can imagine that is truly
inconsistent data
cassandra enforces consistency in
actually a simple way
right you can when you write you can
either wait for
one or all or a quorum of the nodes
to acknowledge the right and the same
with you
when you read so if you read data
if the number of nodes you read from
plus the number of nodes you write from
is more than your replication factor
you're going to
get consistent data so that might mean
you write to all the nodes every time
and read from anyone
might mean you write to one but you
always read from all of them
and just take the most recent or
you write to two and you read from two
and you take the most recent
that's all built into cassandra
the the complexity here is if you look
at
what cassandra says on its wiki it says
in the distributed data systems like
cassandra
consistency usually means that once a
writer has written
all the readers have seen that right
that's true
that's true that that model absolutely
enforces that but if you think about a
case
like one node writing to all the other
nodes
and you have people reading just one
node
while that write is in progress some
some reads are reading the new data
some reads are reading the old data and
sure
when the write is done they'll all get
the new data
but it's probably not consistency like
most people think of consistency
and certainly not consistency like
people moving from relational databases
think of consistency
for our tests we used the right
write write all read one
model of consistency for our test
because it is it is durable for sure
um but it's something to keep aware to
keep in mind when you're trying to
design
your database sure so that means that
you write one basically all the
subsequent
slaves competing for red is complete so
let's say
on one of the nodes you know a raid
cache battery dies right they become
slow
that means that the whole you know set
of notes that connect to it
also slow down is that right okay yeah
yeah
actually it's a really good question so
let's go we're gonna get into this in
some
real details so it kind of defeats their
redundancy in a way
it doesn't it doesn't defeat the
redundancy but it does cause a dramatic
effect
on trying to do consistent rights and so
i i will actually get into that
um in a bit that's one question
what is the uh node count hat is the
note count relevant to these pictures
that you've
been drawing the note count yes assuming
a six um system with a replication
factor of three just drawing it because
yeah i mean is that similar to all the
other pictures
i just want to make sure that i
understand all these pictures that i'm
showing are what you do
if you had a six notes in replication
out of three
in fact our test was four nodes the
resolution factor of two
because we're poor but
this this actually illustrates a little
bit more so i was a little generous in
the picture
okay
um aerospike uh again simpler to
describe it works just like cassandra
when when running in fast mode
for its rights for the for the reliable
mode
it actually has acid semantics so it
does distributed transaction commits and
all the nodes
and behaves in an acid way
all right um this is a big grid which um
i'm not going to go into now because in
the interest of time
but this presentation is available
online
you can look at it if you want what i
want to
talk about is consistency on single node
failure
that's kind of the interesting thing
we're talking about here when you talk
fast or reliable
if one node goes down have you lost data
when we're running in synchronous mode
now when you're running in fast mode
yes
all right so that being said those were
the baselines we set up
the tests actually very simple we put
the databases on the cluster
we tuned the crap out of them and made
sure everything was optimized for the
appropriate hardware according to the
vendor recommendations
all these guys are our partners so they
all helped us you know make sure
everything was tuned
and yielded us a lot when we made
mistakes um
and then we just we load the data set to
a disk just do regular inserts
determine the maximum uh throughput we
can get
either with a sort of a balanced read
write workload or
a 95 read five percent right workload
and then do that again and measure
latency for various levels of traffic
and then repeat the whole thing for the
in-memory the fast case
all right so talking about inserts it's
not the most
important part of this what you can see
is the key value stores were in fact
extremely fast uh both couch-based
narrows by
hundreds of thousands of transactions
per second
uh the ssd scenario here i made sort of
a funny bar
and that just sort of just want to
illustrate why it's so hard to compare
these
uh the issue in this case is couchbase
needs a lot more ram
a lot more metadata in ram for each row
so there was just no way to compare
insert performance
back and forth we had only 200 million
rows of data for couchbase for 500
million rows of data
for aerospike so yes it loaded it
quickly
it's not directly comparable and there's
no way
to balance everything out what we wanted
to do is get the right balance of disk
to ram so i meant different data set
sizes
a more interesting chart is this all
right again
this is for both workloads you could see
the number of transactions we get
against the system
uh when running in fast mode these
things were very fast indeed ranging
from
450 to 900 000 with cassandra and pongo
trailing drastically but not all that
slow with 100 000 for manga
when running in our reliable mode
probably the most obvious thing to note
here is
well two obvious things one aerospike
was an order of magnitude better than
anybody else
and couch base didn't run at all
couch base in theory you know the
underlying disc
was doing about 40 000 operations per
second but
it got bottlenecked by rams this is
something we've
been going back and forth with couch
base on and they hope to release a fix
you know one of the minor versions
coming up but right now
don't try and use couch base in a in a
synchronous way
is is the the main takeaway
all right um i have a lot of these
graphs i'm only showing you a couple the
main thing to see here is
much like what will and mike said
we saw you know less than one
millisecond latencies
all the way up to the top capacity on
both aerospike and couch base
and even for you know [ __ ] and
cassandra for most of their
throughput levels they were very fast
and trailed off
only when they were reaching their
absolute peaks so these these systems
were all quite fast
that's right i just want to confirm so
you're saying the peaks of many of these
are
i mean they're kind of way towards the
left side of the graph and trying to
understand that so
well yeah good question ben we repeat
the question please oh right so the
question was
why are the peaks all the way to the
left side where
and the answer is if you actually
go back because
the maximum load that cassandra [ __ ] is
getting is way less than the maximum
load that the others are getting
so what you see sort of all the way to
the left with cassandra is actually
cassandra maxing out at about 30 000
operations and that's
still having a decent
a fairly thoroughfare uh response time
that's interesting
okay so what was the limitation on that
sorry where's the question is it always
memory that was the limitation i mean
usually what happens is there's usually
an exponential climb
uh similar to kind of maybe the
cassandra on the ram asynchronous
so usually when something maxes out at a
say x
30 000 a second right all of a sudden
i'll see an
exponential climb when it goes to 35 000
almost drops off is unmeasurable
yeah so on the synchronous the
um it was definitely just bound
so i'm sorry the question was what was
the limitation
what what limited these things and
caused these latency slowdowns
in for the synchronous case it was disk
iops for the asynchronous case
you know it's actually the one thing i
said
it's a little hard to tell right here
they seem to be
sort of page swaps but it wasn't
necessarily that easy to know what was
going on
so
sure um i got lost somewhere when you're
talking about
synchronous what are you what are you
referring to here are you talking about
with
you know waiting for the uh the right to
complete is that even by synchronous in
other words the next right won't occur
until the first one completes
right right so the question is what do i
mean by symphonies here
and i should probably have described use
consistent terminology for my for my
slides because i
find the fast and reliable use cases
this just means the reliable use case
that means we will wait
for the replica in this case our
replication factor was two so there's
one replica
we will wait for that replica to be to
confirm that it's been written to
before the market and write is okay and
if possible
we will confirm that the disk has been
written okay now
confirming that the disk has been
written is um
not the whole story because the
this this could be written but the the
fsync might not have run yet
so it might actually be still in sort of
controller memory
and that differs from database to
database um
but the the replica
the replicating to the other replica
is the critical point because if you
lose the node you still have the data
uh are these like oranges and apples in
the sense that cassandra's model is
eventual consistency whereas mongodb
and cash tv they'll work differently uh
in terms of banking ram and give you
that so
when we're looking at this i mean we
could you know if you wanted to
continue to serve any particular purpose
so just want to understand
how were this done i mean were these for
a ad related place because
ssd will crash in certain situations
where i have terabytes
it's just not going to work so what was
the i'm sorry
i didn't find it earlier in the
presentation what was the focus of the
struggling what was looking consistency
across the board
i mean off the cap tier what was cap or
what okay
i'll try and paraphrase your question
sure uh the question is
uh these scenarios um
are they when you say consistency are
you really trying to match consistency
to consistency
are you trying to match the same
consistency levels for databases
and and the answer is sort of
the problem with the term consistency is
that
it means different things fundamentally
so you know couch base is always
consistent
right because it always writes to the
master however
if that master node goes down you've
lost data
yeah maybe you're not screwed and that's
a perfectly there's lots of good uses
for that scenario
and you know as a persistent cache it's
fine
sure the
um so we're not actually measuring that
we're trying to measure
how much do you care about data loss so
what these two scenarios are
are um the asynchronous represents
cassandra running in inconsistent mode
okay the synchronous represents and all
the other databases as well
synchronous represents waiting for that
replica
for another replica to be populated in
cassandra that
means using write all in our test so it
is running cassandra is consistent
so you're forcing it to be consistent
and then measuring
we are right we actually hacked the ycsb
code to have a consistent mode because
that's not something supported
all right so i think the conclusions for
the performance part are obvious
aerospike
claims to be an ssd optimized database
they've written their own drivers to
access the hardware that was
very clearly true in our tests so so
that's why they like us
for the asynchronous way both aerospace
and couchspace were
were just unbelievably fast and the
other databases
really were pretty fast too
this doesn't really it's only answers
with half the questions right that's the
raw performance
the next question is sort of what does
this really mean
in the face of node failures we know you
lose data but what actually happens
so that's what we tried to answer next
so we then sort of created a set of
tests
to disrupt the cluster by taking a node
down
you know this this picture down here was
our hypothesis it was what we expected
to happen
a node goes down we expect the cluster
to be unavailable as
it tries to figure out what the hell
happened comes back up
eventually gets to its original
throughput and then the same thing
happens when you bring a node back up
and
tries to recover from it and then
there's a period of replication
and then you're done so we did this we
modified a whole bunch of parameters
throughput different ways of killing the
nodes
the same scenarios we've talked about
before
and i'm going to walk you through some
pictures quickly that i think
illustrate better than numbers do
all right this first set of pictures
uh describes what happens when you run a
75 percent load
in our fast case we chose 75 percent
load
because if you're taking one node out of
your ford node cluster
you shouldn't expect to be you should
expect to be able to do up to 75 percent
so a perfect system will show no impact
and an imperfect system will show stuff
um
what you can see here is that in the
fast mode these all
basically work sort of similarly to how
they did before um
you know cassandra had some latency
penalties while that node was down
arrows by very little other than a very
brief period of downtime
and the other sort of came in between
there's a little bit you could see in
couch base there's a little bit of
replication
uh traffic at the end because couch base
erases its node
when you rejoin it to the cluster i'm
sorry could you could you
just tell them with the graphs oh i'm
sorry
the question is what do these graphs
mean because they're timing
so the the horizontal axis
is time and the vertical axis is
throughput in operations per second
okay so the top one is operations per
second and the bottom
so the top one's operations per second
the bottom one is latency
so um and they're highly correlated
and all are all graphs on the same scale
they're not on the same scale
the numbers are from the the last one so
you can imagine
aerospikes is we had three hundred
thousand before
um and that's actually
that's a good point which we'll talk
about later sometimes you'll see a big
dip
in one of these graphs that doesn't mean
it's slower than the others it just
means it's lower than it was
it's probably more important to see the
dip because you're going to be using
this for
capacity planning but don't compare them
in absolute terms
all right just sort of to illustrate
what happens here the next thing we did
was you ran it
at 100 capacity which as you might
expect when the node goes down
you've lost you've lost 25 of your
capacity
and you can see that all the databases
except [ __ ] which just uses traditional
master slave
show that behavior and
you could see some of the impact of
getting up to speed a little bit more
at some of the other ones both both
couch pace and aerospike
you know have to work a bit to get up to
that prior level because they're trying
to replicate
against essentially their maximum
capacity um
to me this is i mean it sort of
illustrates why we're doing 75
but you shouldn't be running your
hardware 100 capacity
so probably more interestingly is the 75
version for reliable okay let's see we
have a
question mark shaped couch for
catchphrase because we just couldn't get
it to run
but this this goes uh i think to mike's
question
the case of aerospike um
when you bring down a node and you're
required that you replicate
on each request aerospike does what you
would hope it
something would do and replicates to
when you know it finds a new place to
store the second copy of this data
so it's able to continue processing
transactions throughout the whole period
when you bring that node back up well
you've just been
doing hundreds of thousands of writes
per second
for 10 minutes you've got a lot of
database
uh operations to replicate so there's a
very severe
penalty that lasts for some time
as it tries to bring the node back up
and replicate and bring it the new node
up to date
cassandra mongodb sort of this is the
central question of what we asked
if you're running with only two copies
of data and you're saying right to both
of them
cassandra and mongodb do not relocate
that data
those rights will simply fail so they
simply have downtime
and you know the good news is when they
get back up
there was no data to replicate so it
comes right back up and the
it does for cassandra 2 that's an
artifact of a driver which
is not a particularly interesting story
but but i think the central lesson here
is if you want
consistent data have at least three
copies for these databases
and don't use write all because you're
going to want to see this
in terms of uh total downtime
you know it was a bit a little bit
chaotic then there
seemed to be no pattern as we rerun the
tests but the good news is
all of these databases didn't stay down
very long
all right uh on when you brought a note
down
the worst thing we saw was about 12
seconds of downtime
couch base there's a little special
thing they they take about 45 seconds
but if you write your own
monitoring and recovery scripts which we
did you can get it down very low
and i'm bringing a note up only [ __ ]
had any penalty
really whatsoever about 30 seconds
again this doesn't mean you're at full
capacity this just means
how long is your your cluster down but
our reaction on this was
you know if you're talking about six
seconds of downtime you probably got
other problems
bigger than your database so so from a
downtime perspective these all seem to
work as advertised
another big chart here um
again if you're if you're interested
please download it if you have questions
you i'm happy to go back to it
but the potential data loss here is sort
of
the discussion we sort of calculated
some of the data loss out
assuming the parameters assuming the
results of our test
so i can understand uh
it was a no down replication is this
what does that percentage mean no down
replication is
the the percentage of data
that is um 50
means you have one and a half copies of
your data right which is exactly what
you'd expect if you took down one of
four numbers
and so uh cassandra why does it say n a
there because
cassandra doesn't really accurately
report that number
um you know it reports the number of um
what do we call it i put the name sst's
i forget i get the name of what it has
which it doesn't necessarily clear so
it's a little hard to get sometimes
and then when he comes back he went up
to a 100 with the exception of couch
base which
was up to 76 because it
it takes some time to recover basically
and and measuring the time to recover by
the way
um you know when a node comes up couch
base wipes out that node
and we replicate everything so it's
always sort of showing you the worst
case replication number
um one thing we considered doing
was trying to measure how long does it
take
to achieve sort of full capacity again
the problem is that's not a very
interesting number because if
mongo's doing 20 000 rights per second
and you know couchbase is doing 500
000 writes per second catchphrase is a
much bigger problem to solve so how do
you even compare these numbers
um sort of what you need to know is
that's going to be there you better plan
for it yeah
uh one more question about this i guess
the potential data loss column
or rope i guess there's only two only
aerospace sync and cassandra sync are
the ones that have none all the rest are
susceptible to data loss
in yeah mode and it works that would
also be none
and mongodb in synchronous mode would
also be none
those are not typical running modes for
those two databases
and this table would be completely
unreadable if i included those two in
there
okay so if it's if it's running
synchronously that answer is not
so essentially in typical usage
scenarios
aerospace sanders should be your target
for free targeting data reliability
is that essentially what it is monkodb
can do it too mongodb can do it too
um so
um i'm trying to think about it so let
me repeat the question because i didn't
repeat the question
uh the question is should aerospike and
cassandra
be your databases of choice if you're
targeting reliability
of these four those two are designed
explicitly for that case
so that is a natural setting for them
couchbase claims it is a setting we were
not able to get it to work
mongodb can have that setting we were
able to get it to work
um for these results we found
cassandra and aerospike more compelling
we found them more compelling because
their numbers were higher
for this case mongodb is more of a
document database
we're doing a raw key value store
so we highlighted certain things there's
a lot of data behind these tests
[ __ ] is not a crazy choice
i'm wondering uh how much of this is
really being influenced by the limited
number of servers you're using
uh how much of the so the question
like you had 10 or 20 servers would you
be experiencing these same latencies you
know for recovery
especially if you have you know lots of
redundancy and
replication going on already
to prevent you know failures right i
will
actually this probably is a good the
question is how much of this behavior
is an artifact of our cluster size
um which is a good segue into
the next slide okay
or just two slides from now um
you know the the first thing i would say
addressing this is right
what does it say about mongodb and
cassandra um
if you have a replication factor of 2
well it doesn't work if you want to do
reliable
if you have a replication of factor of 3
it says it won't work
if you're using a write all semantic but
if you're using quorum semantics
it should work i would have loved to
have given
sort of pictures of what's going on in
that case and that is a
you know it's going to be have to
chopped up as a as a to do
the issue there is just very simply
what we were running was bare metal
hardware
with an array of ssds it's actually
pretty expensive to put even a four node
cluster together for this
there is a sort of an analog test which
we're actually doing right now
let's just put put these on ec2 take a
whole bunch of nodes
you're not going to get sort of those
aerospike ssd numbers because
there's there's latency in all the
virtualization and so forth
but you can get a sort of a better
picture of how larger cluster sizes
handle failure
that being said
some of these effects are effects of the
amount of data
right if you have hundreds of millions
of rows that need to be replicated
those hundreds of millions of rows need
to be replicated
and that's go and they need to be
replicated to every node
that's picking it up so obviously if you
have
dozens of copies of this data and one
node down
it's probably not going to affect you
nearly as much
i'm not aware of too many people who
have you know a lot more than three
copies of data
floating around personally i'm not
really aware of people doing that
because your hardware investment goes
through the roof
so for um for the reliable scenario
could you could i
i guess assume that for similar data
reliability i could use a replication
factor of
two for aerospike to get similar
reliability to
commodity being xander is that
okay okay now
with certain caveats if you use two and
you lose both those nodes
you're still going to lose some data
whereas if you use three in mongodb and
cassandra you'll still have a copy
so three is probably a good idea just
across the board
and five is even better right i mean you
have a balance
of how many copies do you want versus
how much you want to invest and how
how much do you want to deal with a
large cluster um
the odds of you know both nodes going
down
in disk catastrophic ways
not not very likely especially because
you can bring another node up and start
recovering immediately
but it's a possibility the odds of three
going down is getting pretty remote
these products do have cross data center
replication right so
your data center getting nuked or
something
could be an issue right there if you
want to get to that highest level of
reliability um
you know cross data center replication
becomes is something to consider but
that
sort of opens a whole new can of worms
because you start to be limited by the
speed of light of getting your data to
the other data center
so you're definitely not getting one
millisecond response times if you're
trying to write to multiple data centers
synchronously so these all in all these
databases allow you to
tune how you do cross data center
replication and that
that also was well beyond the scope of
our lab
all right thanks
did you have a question so i mean the
asynchronous case is sort of the
eventually consistent
one right um and it would seem in that
case that
having greater than two is good because
i think you get voting right
when um in terms of uh
if no goes down or if you have if you
have enough then you can vote on which
which pulling the data back is coming
back from multiple
multiple nodes you can have a voting
thing which determines what the data
should be
right in an eventually consistent system
um is the replication factor of three
good
because you're allowed to vote on which
copy of the data is best
and i like talking about cassandra
because cassandra's
works in a very simple way that makes
these questions easy to illustrate
so the quorum mode of cassandra is if
you're reading from two copies of the
node when you have three
you pick whichever one has a newer
timestamp um
because if it was written to two there
you read these two the one that the
older one must be the wrong one
that's not exactly eventually consistent
that's fully consistent
because you've written two copies and
you're always getting the latest data
the eventually consistent is
the first case we write to one even if
you read from two
neither one of them might have the data
yet so it's not it's not
so the fast scenario is not is still not
is still eventually consistent and the
reliable scenario
is fully consistent
and again the consistent consistency
ends up sort of being the wrong thing
because
um you know mongodb
and couch base will always return a
consistent answer
unless something goes down
in which case they won't
um well i'm starting to repeat myself
here i think i think it's obvious yes
and cassandra can you select how many
nodes
either you're reading from or writing to
on a call by call basis
so the question is in cassandra can you
do the can you
choose the number of notes being read to
or written from on a call by call basis
the answer is yes that is true for
cassandra for mongodb
and for couch base for aerospike it is a
server configuration parameter
uh after having your initial uh load of
data
are you actually having this test player
that actually only the reads data or
there is even a read and write at the
same time too is there a player that
actually reads and writes only reads i'm
sorry
after having the initial right of the
initial
test data are these latencies
for the only the reads or are they even
the rights going on
okay that's a great question because the
reason i'm asking is
the last time i checked there is a
certain read to write ratio mongodb
suggests otherwise it gives a
high latencies so some database have a
certain need to write ratio that they
suggest
and maybe they're in my case in my
situation i found
a respect to be really good irrespective
of whatever the reader write ratio is
so the question is um
are there read and writes occurring on
these databases
concurrently and what is the ratio of
reach to rights
so and and the latencies report we
report are they read latencies or right
latencies
the answer is we've been on several
scenarios here
the ones we're focusing on here consist
of two different scenarios one is
a concurrent blend of 95 percent reads
and five percent rights
that's just sort of a read heavy very
common application scenario
the other one is a 50 50 mix of reads
and writes and so when i show balanced
workload and read heavy workload
that's what those two columns are
are the latencies we're reporting on
that
the answer is we have a lot of those
graphs
and in the interest of time and
boringness
i've only included a very small number
on this report
if you're interested in exactly which
reads which
read latency and right lane you see for
each scenario
we have the full report it's a long
report and has all of these and so you
can examine them
to your heart's content i actually don't
remember which ones i included here
whether those were read latencies or
write latencies
i think i included some read like just
one scenario with just reads and writes
top and bottom
i'm curious why you covered two versions
of powerspace
the question is why did we cover two
versions of couchbase and the answer was
we were doing couch base one eight
and then we turned we learned that this
study was a lot harder than we thought
it was going to be
and they released couchbase 2o so we did
both
did you compare your experience they
performed really
similarly actually
right so the point is that couchbase 2o
has cross data center replication
capabilities
that's true but since we didn't have
multiple data centers it's not was not
one of our test suites
uh catch base 2.0 also has secondary
indexes and a bunch of other features
um couch-based 2-0 also completely
rewrote their storage engine
which made us think that it would have a
dramatic impact
on performance especially in the
synchronous case and we
saw no real significant difference there
neither one really worked
um now again this was when you test
2.0.0
um none of these products were bug free
i'll put that way kasami was probably
the
the least buggy but all of them had
issues
that cropped up that as you sort of
structured certain kinds of tests
but in all the cases except that one
you're able to work through the issues
with the
relevant vendors
yes
mentioned that hbase was also going to
be part of the discussion
did you do that number one number two i
look at the sizes of the aerospike as
well as the sizes that you produce
when you talk about big data i'm
thinking terra and terabytes yeah
that to the gentleman that asked earlier
these
tests are in ssds
i would i cannot do that so
in nosql i'm thinking tera terabytes
because if i have to get
my io will kill me from that perspective
so did you do hbase
or in the pen paper it's on the website
you have hps also
because that would be a true comparison
in my opinion
all right so i think there were two
questions one question is did we do
hbase in our tests the other one is
is this something ssd because if i look
at the configuration of this
sheet it's pretty small i mean it's just
it is yes you you we used is the second
question is gee
you use probably half a terabyte of ssd
capacity
as well as what we use um so the first
question of did we do hbase
um no this was part of our original
grand plan before we decided to simplify
down
as a company we do use hbase as a
company we're actually in process of
trying to quantify it along these same
dimensions
hbase itself you know is built on top of
the hadoop file system which leads to
all kinds of performance issues and
there are companies like mapar
technologies trying to put it on top of
a
of a different file system to get some
better performance out of it
these are all things we're actually
working for in our next report so the
short answer
is is no for hbase but we have some sort
of anecdotal evidence that you're not
going to see numbers like that
the ssd size again
i'm going to have to play poverty half a
terabyte of ssds is
expensive but terabytes and terabytes of
ssds
is even more expensive and so
we chose we put in 500 million rows
relatively small rows for two reasons
one to get a lot of rows in
without completely soaking i mean that
while fitting in those ssds
and two network bandwidth
we've been talking about hundreds of
thousands of transactions per second
it's
pretty easy to saturate your your
network and not learn anything
interesting
right now just i mean just by the way
the whole tv would be a perfect example
the question is did we look at volt db
for this test
the answer is we've certainly looked at
volt db
using volt db as a key value store
didn't seem like a prime use case for
voltdb
using voltdb you know sort of a more
sophisticated comparison based on
secondary index queries versus sql is an
interesting statement
vaultdb for those who don't know is a
distributed
new sql database that allows you to run
much of
you know ansi sql and run sql queries
across a cluster if you relax a few
things
it just wasn't the best fit for the for
this piece
so you mentioned the cost of recipes
when was the last time you looked at the
customers
because the whole i mean i'm thinking
more from a perspective of cloud so
this is a 2g 2b or any application
server
you're sending the data but if i got
current terabytes
xbox one data with exabytes you probably
cannot do something
with a good amount of terabytes you can
do ssd is very cost effective
you would be surprised right i'm just
thinking of the industry of capturing
everything
and anything and i want to reduce
i would think of it this way right so if
you have a large amount of data
and you need answers extremely quickly
you really kind of have two choices
you either use rotational drives and
put enough stuff in your ram put like as
much of your working set in ram as
possible that you're rarely hitting
those drives
or you put it on ssds
if that's not your use case and you just
have tons of data and latency isn't the
problem
that's not the question we're trying to
answer here okay all right that's right
yeah yeah this is for you know
80 seconds your consistent response high
school
generally uh this is not the case of an
emitting silver you know petrified
upgrade
so i realized you didn't do this on ec2
but how hard would it be to
set these systems up for its ssds on pc
the question is how hard is it to set
these systems up with ssds on ec2
the answer it's not hard to set them up
an ec2 has high i o instances that you
can you know play with um
ec2 has other properties that make some
of these things complicated to analyze
so just because it's virtualized there's
sort of unpredictable latencies
and so forth um
we are doing sort of an ec2 follow-up
but
you know when you're studying
low-latency performance
ec2 is not a natural place to start
because it's got unbreakable latency
so believe me i would have made our
lives a lot easier if we could have done
ect for this test
um
larger cluster sizes you know is on our
radar we're working on that
right now and we're using ec2 for that
um but i don't have
meaningful results for you yet
um so you spoke earlier about having to
do a lot of configuration
which is often the source of problem in
comparing these
different systems how would you
recommend
like an engineer to go around doing that
if you didn't have access to your
partner
or taxes well
so the question is given that we did a
lot of configuration and given that we
talked trash about earlier studies
on paraphrasing how would you how do you
actually
configure these systems
this is one of the reasons why we put
this together so we go into extreme
detail on the
papers themselves of how we set these
systems up
so that's a good place to start
the vendors themselves will help you
you know aerospa if you're installing
aerospike
and you talk to aerospike and say how do
i get better performance using this kind
of hardware they're going to come in and
they're going to
help you because this is their bread and
butter
for the cassandra datastax has a ton of
free documentation on their site
what parameters to relax in their
experience for ec2
and so forth and so
similarly couchbase has a lot of
information on how to size your cluster
and so forth
so it's there just
it takes some work it takes some work so
i hope that the papers we
release gives you a head start to get in
there
so similar question um in terms of
amount of time
it took to learn and to get operational
with each of these four stocks
um probably good thing you didn't throw
a hbase in otherwise it would have been
crazy but what uh was there any any
learnings there
um the question was were there learnings
on the amount of time it takes to get to
learn these databases well
from our perspective that was the
biggest learning curve we were as i said
wildly optimistic we're like we'll be
done in a month
i'm going to put a couple engineers on
it and it took us like three and a half
months to get that first paper out
because um and that was dramatically
reducing
number of databases so the big learnings
are
trying to get fair answers is really
hard
luckily you probably won't have that
exact problem you don't care if it's
fair you just want to learn your
individual database so that's going to
be
you know divide by four at least
the other learning from our side is be
prepared to throw out the majority of
your data
which is painful but you got to do it so
so we did it we learned i mean we
gathered a lot of data
understood why that data was wrong and
then
moved on from it and it's not here
telling me the sense of many iterative
tests yeah
that were failed or consistent for one
reason a lot of things like
gee that looks kind of funny why would
that be the case it doesn't make a whole
heck of a lot of sense
let's investigate on a deeper level
what's going on here in terms of
replication
oh that's probably not what you want to
do under high load
let's try messing with this a bit oh
that makes more sense
there's a lot of that going on
good question um i guess do you have any
um any experience like cursory or
otherwise with
i guess some of the relational databases
are trying to like kind of bridge the
gap like something like
is like adding native json support and
internal javascript support and the
the benchmarks seem to be fairly close
with at least some of them
and do you do you see that as like kind
of a
i don't know like if you don't have that
much hardware and you want to like kind
of consolidate and pick one
does it make sense like performance wise
to use a relational database for in that
type of
use case or is that is that not a good
code is that not a good use
the question is does it make sense to
use a relational database
for this kind of use case um
well that's the question right and so
the answer is it's it's not it's
certainly not crazy and in fact
before nosql was a thing that's exactly
what we did
you know client come in and and their
sql databases were sort of
collapsing and they're joining
everywhere and we just worked with the
application and denormalized and
started storing things in key value-like
ways
and it made it much much easier to shard
the data to multiple servers
um you can use replication to go across
and in fact you know this is what you
know
what you know twitter does for example
if you've looked into something like
gizzard and flockdb have you looked into
that at all
so what these are these are you know
twitter basically wants to maintain a
graph all right and
so it's who's following whom um
just writes essentially single key value
records into lots and lots of mysql
and then has a layer to distribute the
load
and balance that load it's a totally
reasonable thing to do
i would argue that this is a lot easier
to do
um because these have all these features
built in
we did not have to write something like
gizzard to get these clusters to come up
and down and we messed with the network
and when you do something like that with
a relational database
you need to be you need to frame your
operations fairly carefully
so as an example you know twitter has a
fairly simple use case they have one
directional
you know relationships between people
facebook
also using my sequel um has
bi-directional relationships you friend
someone they're your friend back
that means every right needs to go to
two different places
and those might be inconsistent they
have to handle that eventual consistency
themselves
so they have repair processes running
trying to find consistent data
and get them back into sync
that's that's a lot to deal with um
so at least do you see are there if you
were to do that even if it's
stupid uh is there like similar
components between the two or
it's it's not stupid it's not stupid the
question is is there a similar
performance if you do that
we do do that as well but i'd say manual
sharding
the issue isn't i mean you're not
getting performance
we have not gotten performance anything
like hundreds of thousands of operations
per second doing that we have gotten
performance
of you know more like ten thousand okay
um those systems have been in production
they work fine
but they're a pain to manage so for
instance we have an application which
again it's like a it's affiliated with
facebook and we're maintaining your
social graph
um
we have to hit the shards in the right
way each shard
is using standard master slave
replication somewhere else
now we want to change the schema somehow
do we break replication update it one
place updated the other
re-establish replication it's a lot of
maintenance
the advantage is it's a very very well
understood technology
so you're not going to hit that tippy
top level of scale it might be enough
scale for what you want to do
but i would seriously consider the cost
of maintaining such an infrastructure
the question was uh is it crazy to use
a relation database in the way we use no
sql database
so the wheels report we're talking about
no sql databases
and the no scale layer around that
the fact is in our system we actually
use
relational mysql database is one of the
components working in the same framework
actually that allows us to file to start
one project
much faster just using the experience
developers head on just developing
regular sql databases
so we just use that experience we
started faster but we're absolutely
ready to switch that project to the
nosql database
the way we're using mysql now is
the nosql way so it's absolutely no
crazy
and it absolutely works you can also end
up in memory slaves there's these things
you can do
you know should you get it right yeah
sometimes
so what kind of performance difference
do you see between the relational
oh it's it's pretty good we're not
talking here about
hundreds of thousands transactions per
second but it's sufficient for the task
okay right it's uh
thousands transactions a second it's
pretty good but the
table structure is very simple
it's uh key value storage pretty much
the same type we use in the
sql network okay simple layer is one
huge advantage you can actually see
what's going on here
so that's what mike said it's a good
start
like just to develop your application
against it and
you know verify the data is
you know you read in the right makes
sense uh
and then swap with your heart for the
tools to facilitate their edges
and then you can swap it for your higher
performance engine
so um just talking about the sequel and
now thing one of the things i was
recently looking for
i can't think of the name right now but
it was developed by the company stripe
that makes online payments
and they created a project that takes my
sequels tail
logs and replicates it to postgres so
that they have
their backend database and they can do
all the analysis and all that and they
use
mongodb sorry mongodb as a front end
for our data and then they keep
replicating it real time to postpress so
that they have
um that back of data
so i mean it's a good combination
essentially what you've said is there's
a company
that produces something that can take uh
mongodb replication logs
or my sql replication logs and replicate
to postgres or other databases um
that's what's traditionally called
polyglot persistence
you know what what we can talk about
some of the disadvantages of nosql to
begin with
or maybe the advantages of sql databases
which is sql databases are very very
good at running
sort of arbitrary queries joining
against things and so forth
these are our facilities that you give
up when you move to nosql
it's what you trade to get some of the
scalability
so you know most organizations can't
live without that in the end
so when we're when we're talking about
these kinds of things
you know if we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of transactions the front
end you're not doing that
in the sql database and you're certainly
not joining
um the
but you do want to analyze that data so
at some point you know
most everyone i know is taking that data
off that bringing it into
some kind of analytical storage either a
sql database
or a data warehouse of some kind and
analyzing the data there
it's extremely common it
most people i know i've had just sort of
homegrown solutions
to to pull out and write in but i'm sure
there are a ton of products that do it
as well
right so um probably the best
way of doing that that we found because
we looked at this extensively
is you need to have this huge data set
available very very
you know highly available and it's very
high throughput low latency
and at the same time in the analytical
storage
is um you stream this data into a log
as you write it uh to the nosql engine
and then this log is being fed you know
you know real-time processing systems
into your
data warehouse and then you just
spinning your baby into parallel things
otherwise you have to extract a snapshot
you save it
it takes a long time by the time you're
done it's already changed
so it's very very painful um
so the plug uh
in a month we're going to be hosting a
verifica meetup here in this office
which is a you know
a very high performance very fast sql
database
um you know data warehouse stack and
digital database
so we actually use both engines for this
type of stuff
is that what you use primarily i mean
you said simple do you use mysql and
vertical or just for the gun network uh
my
my secondary card
is good for beat operations
right then you can't really do
transactional stuff there so anything
where i have to have transactionalized
consistency
you use my sql
yeah it's quite uh anything that has an
ancient
in its name
i'm going to resume the presentation but
i suspect that the next slide is asking
for questions
not quite um but this is
probably stuff we talked about finite
wealth was a serious problem in a lot of
the tests
we recognize that but it's a problem we
have
another thing is we when we created
these failures we tried to create them a
lot of different ways
we did network split brain we killed
processes
brutally we killed them nicely didn't
learn too much interesting
these applications tended to work unless
you did
really bizarre things like one-way
network failures but
it's a lab it's not the real world i'm
sure you're going to find ways to break
this
we just didn't find it and i you know i
mentioned a bit
some of the issues with trying to tr
track replication delays and so forth
um again i think
the questions addressed a lot of this we
do need to evaluate larger clusters
we're doing that on ec2 the results
won't be directly comparable because we
don't have the same latency but at least
we can do larger clusters
um and then moving beyond the key value
store
is another whole can of worms which we
have to find the right base lines for
but we're researching it
and if you guys sure so have you i mean
you know he met anybody who used an ec2s
or a
disaster recovery kind of uh environment
and then
would accept you know more performance
but you know consistent performance
somewhat
if they had to bring it up so that's not
the main production but
uh you know get get it to a point where
it still works
you know you don't get five milliseconds
you get you know 15 milliseconds but
it doesn't die on you so the question is
do we know
someone who's using ec2
as sort of a hot spare production
i don't but i know i mean for instance
netflix runs their whole infrastructure
off
of cassandra on ec2
uh but you can definitely do that the
question is
netflix doesn't have to
do these types
i don't know anybody who does that
sounds reasonable i don't know anyone
who does that
um so if there is a specific database i
heard hbase which we're already looking
at
just you know let me know and we'll try
to get it in
and so lastly again you know with
thumbtack this is what we do
if you want the the presentation you can
download a slightly updated updated
sound version right there
the papers are available at the other
link
they're long but they have really a lot
of detail in them
if you want to contact me there's there
seems to be only one ben amber on the
internet
and my my handle is bainburg for pretty
much everything
so any last questions did you look at
the er
no um i am personally very interested in
reacting it is
um it's an interesting technology
it's something that almost never comes
up in our conversations
so it sort of got de-prioritized i kind
of pushed for react to be included
in this study and it just didn't make
sense because we just never hear
interest in it
all right thank you thank you one more
question
um
i've heard anything about some of these
more real time reading
tools like google's dremel or
meta markets when we screw it the more
real-time
real-time data stores the question is
do i know much about real-time data
stores like google's dremel
or i already forgot the second one
because the answer is no this is not
it's just leaving my area of expertise i
don't know
too much about it i know i know
companies who are doing real-time
analytics
on top of [ __ ] actually chartbeat does
that
a number a number of companies do that
not so familiar with the technologies
they're talking about